since 1997 blizzard's diablo series has
been a much beloved pc staple offering
up hundreds of hours of fast-paced
dungeon crawling and loot grinding set
in a dark fantasy world overrun by
demons and other monstrous creatures now
however diablo is preparing for its most
ambitious and widespread release yet
mobile announced back in 2018 to fan
shock and even frustration do you guys
not have phone the first pocket size
diablo game is almost upon us so here is
everything you need to know about diablo
immortal for all you diablo fans who
can't get enough of the grim dark world
of sanctuary you'll be pleased to know
that diablo immortal actually fleshes
out the time period between diablo 2 and
diablo 3 a bit more than we've
previously seen
set 5 years after the events of diablo 2
a mortal takes place in the town of
wortham a sleepy little village of
hardly any consequence at all until it's
threatened by hordes of cultists and the
undead players then learn from diablo
fan favorite deckard kane that to
restore peace to the hamlet and
subsequently the world they must travel
across sanctuary to track down and
destroy shards of the world stone
preventing a necrotic calamity however
in the midst of all that chaos is yet
another struggle the conflict between
the immortals and the shadows referred
to as the cycle of strife
according to the game's lore the
conflict first began when a powerful
woman named the odessa the builder gave
birth to two children keon and akiba
to her son keon she gifted an artifact
known as the eternal crown and bestowed
upon him the responsibility of
protecting sanctuary from the undead
ultimately keon used his power and the
crown to create the immortals an
organization focused on protecting the
realm
however to her daughter akiba dedesa
gave an even greater responsibility to
live in the shadows constantly
challenging and testing her brother's
vigilance in order to ensure the
immortals were always worthy of their
station
akiba thus formed a group known as the
shadows with the understanding that if
they were ever able to overtake the
immortals they would then become
immortals themselves so with all that
going on you'll be set out into the
world and you'll get to explore areas
like ash world cemetery the dark woods
the chansar sea mount zavin and the
frozen tundra while diablo immortal
retains the action role-playing elements
in isometric perspective synonymous with
the series what sets it apart from its
predecessors is that it's a free-to-play
mobile-based mmo and is therefore
structured to accommodate that style of
gameplay
blizzard has confirmed that while the
game will have dungeons not dissimilar
to those found in the pc and console
games they will be quite a bit shorter
averaging 10 to 15 minutes in length to
make them more digestible for mobile
players the studio also confirmed that
much like world of warcraft and other
mmos you will be able to see other
characters on the map and use voice chat
to communicate with friends adding a new
level of interactivity to the series
lastly immortal has also done away with
the series mana system in favor of a
cooldown system that's more in line with
traditional mmos but promises it will
never turn to an energy system that
limits the amount of free play time a
player can sync into the game in a
single day a frequent complaint with
mobile games
the gameplay is also designed to be
played on the touchscreen so it will
feature virtual overlay controls though
it will also support keyboard and mouse
as well as a connected gamepad another
notable change too is that you can
actually move and attack simultaneously
which is not something you could do in
previous games upon starting a mortal
players can choose from 6 returning
character classes each with 12 unique
skills to unlock barbarian wizard monk
necromancer demon hunter and crusader
throughout the campaign players will
gain experience points that allow them
to increase their level up to the game's
current level cap of 60. once they hit
level 60 you can then achieve paragon
levels which can be invested into four
different skill trees survivor treasure
hunter vanquisher and gladiator
blizzard has already confirmed that it
plans on increasing the level cap adding
even more abilities and implementing
battle passes in the game as well
while the core of immortals is single
player it also boasts several
multiplayer activities as well players
will be allowed to join up in parties of
four to play through dynamic events
together in order to take on tougher
dungeons and earn better loot further at
level 45 players will unlock the
heliquery where they can hunt trap and
beat boss demons in 8 player party raids
which when completed can grant character
bonuses the development team hopes to
introduce new bosses every single month
the game also features pvp modes
including a basic 8 vs 8 battleground
mode and the cycle of strife a pvp
system open to players who have reached
immortals end game here players can join
either the immortals or shadows faction
or simply be adventurers shadows will
work to offset immortal players by
completing different shadows activities
while immortals will do the same one
example that the developers gave of
these activities was kion's ordeal a 48
player raid with groups of 12 players
fighting four bosses at the same time
once the shadows have progressed against
the immortals enough the right of exile
will trigger where the top player from
the immortals will become a boss and
must defeat the top 30 shadows players
in a 30v1 battle if the immortals win
nothing changes but if the shadows win
all 30 players are resurrected in a
battle royale to decide which shadow
clan becomes the new immortals starting
a new cycle the diablo immortal team
plans for these cycles to last between
one and three months at a time while the
diablo games might be known for their pc
presence blizzard initially stated that
diablo immortal would strictly be a
mobile game a fact that caused a lot of
tension back when it was announced
however blizzard eventually announced
that the game will be coming to pc
meaning that you'll be able to
experience diablo mortal on its home
turf there will even be cross play
meaning that you can switch where you
want to murder the forces of hell at
your will
even beyond that while there's been
little specifics there will also be
cross progression meaning that most
likely you'll be able to play as your
character on both pc and mobile letting
you jump back and forth between the two
platforms without losing any experience
or loot on top of that as the game was
initially designed for mobile the game
won't be too taxing on any pc so as long
as you have a basic setup you should be
good to go
though to note the game will be in open
beta on pc at launch sadly however no
announcement of if the game will be
coming to consoles has yet been
forthcoming
since diablo immortal was a mobile game
first it is completely free to play
meaning you don't have to pay a single
dime to kill some demons
even further blizzard stated that the
game would also not include any
pay-to-win mechanics but you know diablo
players are used to grinding their way
through levels however there will be a
battle pass with free and paid tracks
there are 40 free and 40 paid ranks each
requiring battle points to unlock which
you earn by completing specific
activities there will also be a 5 option
to unlock the battle pass while 15
unlocks 14 ranks as for the release date
diablo immortal is set to launch on june
2nd 2022 at 10am pdt in most areas of
the world on mobile it will be released
in full but on pc it will still be an
open beta blizzard did note however that
some folks may notice the game rolling
out on the apple app store and google
play starting june 1st so keep your eyes
peeled if you want to download the game
early
further diablo immortal will launch an
open beta on pc android and ios in some
asian pacific regions on june 22 pdt
including hong kong indonesia macau
malaysia the philippines singapore
taiwan and thailand immortal will also
launch on that same day in vietnam but
for pc and open beta only
and all of those regions will receive
dedicated game servers if you want to
play diablo immortal on pc you can
preload the game on your computer from
battle.net right now so as soon as the
game launches on june 2nd you can be
ready to go at the first possible moment
sadly as it's free to play you're out of
luck if you're looking for a fancy
steelbook game case or some sweet
pre-order swag however you can
pre-register to play the game at diablo
immortal's official website at this
point most of the beta tests and other
benefits have already passed from
pre-registering but there may be other
rewards and news that you may get by
doing so also before we wrap up it's
worth mentioning that activision
blizzard has been in the news a lot
lately and not just because it was
acquired by microsoft it's also
currently facing ongoing allegations of
harassment leveled against the company
in general as well as general ethics
violations as well as misconduct
allegations leveled at current ceo bobby
coddick if you want to learn more about
that situation we have linked further
information in the description that goes
into detail
and that's everything we have about the
upcoming diablo immortal it's been a
rocky road for this game pre-release but
hopefully once it's out in your hands
literally it'll still prove worthy of
the name diablo for more on diablo
immortal as well as everything in the
series make sure you subscribe to the
channel right here on gamespot until
next time thanks for watching